on a un ouvrier qui qui est tombé qui a
traumatisme au niveau de sa colonne
vertébrale donc on doit le remonter avec
le plus de précautions possibles
[Applaudissements]
la difficulté ne vient ni de la hauteur
ni de la profondeur mais de l'étroitesse
de la fosse
[Musique]
il voulait sortir des plateaux prendre
l'air tâter le terrain
ils ne vont pas être déçus
Carole Rousseau et Benjamin Castaldi
partent à la rencontre d'hommes et de
femmes ordinaires au métier
extraordinaire
[Musique]
aujourd'hui immersion immédiate au sein
du grimpe le groupe d'intervention au
milieu périlleux les pompiers de
l'extrême ceux qui interviennent là où
les autres soldats du feu ne vont pas
être mise en tension les
sapeurs-pompiers de Paris sont 8500
seuls 18 à partir de grimpes la crème de
la crème je vais passer quatre jours
avec eux c'est à dire que je suis très
très mal moi oh je vais me faire
peur dans les airs donc on descend déjà
les fesses au maximum
sous la terre et dans le vide je vais
apprendre à maîtriser mes émotions pas
épargner tellement je vais découvrir les
joies de l'élitroyage
[Musique]
faire le grand saut dans la scène
je vais tout donner pour suivre ces
hommes aguerris à la forme physique
irréprochable
à la vache et je sais que je vais
bénéficier de l'oreille attentive de
Carole curieuse de mon séjour au sein de
cet univers très masculin bonjour
monsieur des vrais pompiers
suivez moi en exercice comme mon
intervention auprès de ce corps d'élite
qui s'entraîne 7 jours sur 7 pour faire
face aux situations les plus
acrobatiques
oh c'est haut
pour les les jours à venir donc voilà
petite tenue rouge
[Rires]
et c'est à cette tenue rouge que l'on
reconnaît un membre du grimpe pour 4
jours je suis le 19e homme je vais les
suivre en mission je vais vivre avec eux
voilà
ah là ça coupe là
ça fait partie du rituel ça aussi hein
j'adorerais le faire
[Rires]
coupe à zéro et cordes la séance de
sport est quotidienne la condition
physique des pompiers c'est leur survie
et leur efficacité
et pour se tester une épreuve redoutable
mythique avec laquelle on ne triche pas
la planche
se redresser
sans l'aide des jambes à la vache
sur une planche à 2 mètres 40 du sol
normalement celui qui la monte pas au
moins à 15 donc les deux coups dans
simultané il est censé ne pas monter
dans les camions mais ça c'est
quoi c'est un balcon qui s'effondre
ça fait déjà plus loin
et l'autre
[Musique]
je laisse tomber pour le moment mais
avant la fin je vais y arriver je me
retrouve entre les mains d'un des doyens
du grain Thomas 15 ans de service il
mène ici au Baba de leur métier
c'est le baudrier qu'on utilise sur
intervention
Modric
j'ai l'impression de partir en haute
montagne comme pour l'escalade les
pompiers du grimpe utilisent des cordes
des python des mousquetons
le grimpe n'intervient jamais en premier
il arrive en renfort lorsque les
pompiers classiques se retrouvent
bloqués lorsque les opérations sont hors
normes la mission de ce commando de
l'impossible passez coûte que coûte pour
évacuer la victime ou pour arriver
jusqu'à elle
en 2014 le gramme de Paris est intervenu
130 fois une opération tous les trois
jours la plupart du temps on fait des
bancsardages en façade d'accord on
évacue des personnes soit de fortes
corpulence ou qui nécessitent une
évacuation horizontale d'accord qui
passerait pas par la porte ou des
escaliers sont trop raides donc le plus
simple on ouvre la fenêtre on met un
système de corde on passe le grand car
par la fenêtre un sauveteur qui tient et
on descend jusqu'au sol d'accord il est
pris en charge par les médecins par
l'ambulance
une fenêtre une corde un brancard ça a
l'air simple
au cœur de la caserne ce bâtiment vide
permet aux pompiers de répéter les
manœuvres de base
pour pouvoir les suivre je dois vite
assimiler le minimum vital question de
sécurité et je découvre que ma vie ne va
plus tenir qu'à un fil d'accord cette
petite lanière là qui nous tient là
ouais c'est ça
paraît petit mais ça résiste largement
pour un corps humain d'accord le nœud
l'accorde le mousqueton il y a pas de
problème rien se passer on accroche plus
lourd qu'un point d'homme d'accord on
descend en dessous pour refaire
l'installation
garde et mousquetons résiste à une
charge de 2000 kg
voilà fameuse corde elle est là
on a installé notre descendeur
on l'ouvre
le plus dur c'est de se détendre de
faire confiance et de se laisser guider
et ce n'est pas naturel du tout
une fois que tu es confort donc la main
droite et elle va toujours garder le
brin à droite d'accord
de sécurité
d'accord là tu es prêt à descendre quand
je descends
tu vois que la sécurité elle fonctionne
là tu as la paume vers le ciel vers le
ciel
n'a jamais au dessus d'accord
j'ai entendu mettez jambes
tu peux te retrouver debout comme ça
12 mètres du solide
trop vite tes jambes
d'accord donc on descend déjà les fesses
au maximum
là vous voyez une jambe
laisse bien coulisser dans ta main
droite
premier appel un régal et surtout
j'adore le son des mousquetons
mais si j'ai bien en main mon matériel
de base baudrier descendeurs et
mousquetons je vais vite regretter mon
petit immeuble d'entraînement de 4
étages
pour moi les choses sérieuses commencent
premier exercice gendant nature un
grutier est bloqué dans sa cabine les
premiers secours n'ont pas réussi à le
redescendre ils ont fait appel au gars
du grain
ce sont les seuls à maîtriser les
techniques de secours dès que
l'évacuation est trop compliquée
un seul accès pour atteindre le grutier
à secourir l'échelle étroite qui grimpe
au cœur de la structure
la griffe environ 60 mètres
déjà franchement
je suis pas super
je rejoins le grutier qui pour
l'exercice va jouer la victime
[Musique]
mais c'est plus haut encore que le
gramme travail alerte libre sur la
flèche au niveau du toit de la cabine
je vais te dire que je suis très très
mal moi
au plus tard
[Rires]
c'est le vide en dessous
bon alors blague à part
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de ce grutier
là bonjour première difficulté c'est que
il faut le sortir de
sa cabine
je peux pas passer le brancard par
l'extérieur tu es obligé de le remonter
ici pour après le repasser à l'extérieur
ici la grue
il va être suspendu au-dessus du vide là
je ne fais pas la victime
c'est plus facile à dire qu'à faire
la sensation du vide est terrifiante et
marche sur la Green arrange rien elle
semble si légère on a l'impression
qu'elle va céder à chaque pas
celle-là
52 mètres de haut des pieds au dessus du
vide c'est un cauchemar
pour le grain c'est une première ils
n'ont jamais travaillé sur ce type de
grue ils doivent vite trouver une
solution
Nicolas dirige la manœuvre pour être vu
de tous il est le seul à porter un
casque blanc
bon à part moi d'accord
je vais un peu mieux qu'il y a 10
minutes
donc Thomas
donc derrière toi derrière toi en fait
au-dessus de toi décide où seront fixés
les poulies et les cordes il veille à la
sécurité de tous amis
la sécurité doit être absolue
Thomas mon instructeur est chargé de
descendre la victime
[Musique]
sous mes pieds dans l'espace confiné de
la cabine le grutier et sanglé à la
civière
chaque nœud est vérifié
avec précaution à l'aide d'un treuil la
manœuvre commence
sous les ordres de Nicolas
[Musique]
à la verticale parfaitement immobilisée
le grutier se retrouve suspendu dans le
vide
dans un calme qui me sidère il se laisse
descendre
et tenez vous bien c'est moi qui
commande le treuil
Anna les obstacles sont surmontés
[Musique]
60 mètres en moins de 5 minutes le
blessé est récupéré fin de l'exercice
et mon bizutage commence
[Musique]
et elle ne me loupe pas
leur terrain de jeu c'est une zone de 7
millions d'habitants dans laquelle il
doit pouvoir intervenir en moins d'une
heure
[Applaudissements]
cet après-midi l'exercice se fait avec
les plongeurs des sapeurs-pompiers de
Paris
rendez-vous au Pont-Neuf
c'est le deuxième exercice de la journée
le scénario un noyer a été repêché il
faut l'évacuer
[Musique]
j'étais loin d'imaginer qu'il fallait
une telle installation un tel
déploiement d'énergie de matériel juste
pour remonter un blessé
deux corps entre le pont et la berge
forment une tyrolienne elle va porter le
brancard qui sera hissé sur le pont
cette technique de brancardage par les
airs grâce à des cordes ils sont les
seuls à la maîtriser sur Paris
donc le blessé est sur la scène il est
dans l'eau
et l'objectif c'est de le remonter ici
sur la voie publique
on est obligé
de
venter ce serait utile on est dans une
un lieu où il y a des berges fautes
voilà exactement pas d'accès donc on
vous appelle parce qu'on peut pas
évacuer le que ce soit en exercice en
intervention le temps est toujours
compté voilà ni une demi-heure on doit
être installé une demi-heure c'est pas
un peu long quand il est vite fait en
jeu
non parce que comme on n'arrive pas à
les on n'est pas les premières
intervenants donc voilà ils sont déjà
pris en charge donc du coup on a un peu
ça nous laisse du temps maintenant on va
au plus vite mais on peut pas être plus
rapide qui dit plus rapide après c'est
danger puis c'est accident c'est
beaucoup moins que ce matin j'ai moins
de mal à jouer la victime
comme j'aime bien l'eau moi le fait
qu'il y a de l'eau en dessous ça me
rassure quand même je me dis s'il y a un
pépin je tombe à la flotte quoi au pire
on met attention les dispositif on se
met en tension de ce côté là
on verra ouais bah non
c'est bon
on se dérange
et très stable très agréable et qui me
sécuriser ses bons
démontage
l'exercice est terminé et maintenant un
délire qui me tient à cœur en 77 Chirac
la promis aujourd'hui je le fais
[Musique]
allez on remonte sur le côté
c'est énorme il paraît que la qualité de
l'eau s'améliore dans la Seine j'espère
bien
ce serait vraiment dommage de choper la
tourista à Paris
je ne suis pas mécontent de me rincer
j'avais tout prévu sauf de boire l'eau
de la Seine
[Musique]
il n'est que 18h mais je suis bien
content de retrouver la caserne dans les
couloirs une sonnerie annonce un départ
immédiat
pas de panique c'est une ambulance
classique qui est envoyée pas le grain
[Musique]
cé et pourtant ce n'était que des
exercices
[Musique]
quand même aujourd'hui mine de rien
c'est le bon moment de partager mes
premières impressions avec Carole
[Musique]
ah bah oui regarde il y a même des il y
a même des pompiers qui sont là
la journée ne s'arrête jamais en fait
l'entraînement est absolument permanent
c'est-à-dire que quand il y a pas
d'intervention il s'entraîne dans
différents cas de figures soit récupéré
quelqu'un sur une paroi soit évacuer
quelqu'un
[Musique]
le plus compliqué pour moi c'était de
m'habituer à à
la hauteur j'ai pas le vertige a priori
mais on est quand même dans des
configurations où on n'a pas l'habitude
de se balader en haut d'une grue avec le
avec 50 mètres d'aplomb quoi
[Musique]
alors je pense qu'il y a pas pour eux il
y a pas d'échec en termes de de
sauvetage qui peut pas y avoir d'échecs
une victime elle sera toujours extraite
alors elle serait pas forcément sauvée
parce qu'il peut arriver soit trop tard
soit dans les situations malheureusement
la personne est décédée donc il faut
juste la descendre mais pour eux dans
tous les cas de figure ils vont ils vont
réussir à en tous les cas arriver sur le
le lieu où ils doivent intervenir
toujours et à trouver la solution pour
redescendre la victime toujours
et pendant que je parle à Carole Fred
mon coloc Rafistol mon pantalon
[Rires]
ce sera bien comme ça il sera dans la
même tenue que les autres
SP pour sapeur-pompiers demain toute la
journée je vais sauter courir grimper en
tenue de feu la tenue de combat des
sapeurs-pompiers
et demain la journée encore un peu
longue je crois
bas
c'est franchement elles sont confort
c'est là 6h du matin pas le temps de
traîner
[Musique]
encore un truc que je n'avais vu que
dans les films la perche de feu
promis je ferai mieux la prochaine fois
les gars sont déjà en train de vérifier
leur matos il attendent plus que moi
j'ai tout mais j'ai pas la baisse de feu
SMS à Carole
en tenue de feu au milieu d'une
trentaine de pompiers
départ dans une minute pour le binôme 3
le grimpe ne doit pas oublier les
fondamentaux ce matin avec d'autres
unités de sapeur-pompier il se mesure au
parcours que toute jeune recrue doit
réussir en fin de formation
c'est à la fois une course de fond et un
travail de force le dérouleur pèse 200
kg
sans compter que la tenue n'est pas
légère entre le casque qui pèse 1 kg 360
les Rangers 1 kg 3
la veste le surpentalon j'ai près de 8
kg sur le dos pas idéal pour un marathon
mais c'est dans cette tenue que ces
athlètes affrontent les incendies
[Musique]
je suis déjà au bout du rouleau mais la
fête ne fait que commencer maintenant
c'est un jeu de piste
[Musique]
mes compagnons ont 15 ans de moins que
moi je commence à le sentir
[Musique]
c'est pour aller au drapeau je n'ai plus
vraiment l'âge de jouer les Yamakasi
[Musique]
allez donc nous allons procéder à la
proclamation des résultats de cette
épreuve
à la troisième place
tout de suite et dans le rouge direct
les échelles ça se passe bien et après
on cavale tout le temps quoi
j'étais au bout du mal et je suis pas le
dernier
sieste
pendant que je me repose mais camarades
de Marathon préparent une nouvelle
ascension chacun a sur le dos ça part
des 100 kg de matériel
toujours à la recherche de nouveaux
défis de nouvelles sensations le grain
par repérer une petite merveille une
grue mais pas n'importe laquelle la plus
grande sur Paris en ce moment sa flèche
culmine à 120 mètres de hauteur
[Musique]
Bellevue parisienne tu peux de soleil
encore
35 m 40
tout est ici à la force des bras
l'ascension dure un quart d'heure pour
se retrouver finalement bien au-dessus
des toits Paris à nos pieds balayé par
un vent frais
même Juan le chef d'unité avec ses 21
ans de service c'est impressionné ah
c'est une des plus hautes grues sur
laquelle je suis monté
il y a du vent donc la grue elle est
elle est en girouette pour éviter que le
vent force sur la grue du coup il la
laisse libre d'elle-même de pouvoir
tourner avec le vent et là c'est ce qui
se passe en train de tourner
et comment on gère la peur quand même
parce que c'est impressionnant n'importe
qui à 120 m au rétro il y a
c'est pas c'est pas du naturel on se
remet pas dans le vide naturellement
routine en fait on pense qu'on est en
sécurité et puis finalement quand on
regarde à deux fois ça nous rappelle à
l'ordre
la progression est prudente ils sont
attachés en permanence à une ligne de
vie
[Musique]
quand ils interviennent au bout d'une
grue là où le risque de chute et le plus
grand là où ils sont le plus seul c'est
la plupart du temps pour les secourir
des forçonnées des suicidaires
[Musique]
ils doivent assurer calmer la victime
gagner sa confiance pour la sécuriser
avant de la redescendre
[Musique]
un mètre doucement doucement doucement
on est au sol oui
un quart d'heure d'ascension 40 minutes
de mise en place 3 minutes de descente
et 600 mètres de corde à ranger
malheureusement quand ce n'est plus une
simulation quand des vies sont en danger
ça ne finit pas toujours aussi bien j'ai
déjà eu une intervention que ça
m'intériée avec une personne que je
rattrape et qui me lâche et qui tombe
donc ça reste ça rappelle tout le temps
de toute façon le travail continue les
interventions continuent
on est là pour le soutenir
on en parle pas chez soi on en parle pas
à ses amis civils on en parle contre
personne qui connaissent les mêmes
situations
et on arrive quand même à passer
pour la première fois je sens derrière
les rires entre potes de belles amitiés
forgés à coup d'intervention parfois
dramatique
en 2014 le grain passe que rue 5
personnes menaçant de se jeter dans le
vide
on arrive à prendre mon pied d'appel
pour arriver sur le sur la victime là il
me met un coup il me voit il me met un
coup et donc avec la longueur de corde
je repars je repars je fais un grand
ballon et quand je reviens sur lui la
victime il met un coup de pied il se
jette dans le vide quoi et juste quand
j'arrive sur lui il chute et j'arrive
juste à l'attraper avec mes jambes quand
même cercle avec mes jambes mais à deux
sur le descendeur du coup on chute donc
je fais juste une une clé comment tu as
appris je fais une demi-clé comme ça je
le tiens avec mes jambes et je suis la
demi-clé comme ça et avec le choc il me
glisse des jambes et communiquer juste
en caleçon donc j'ai aucune je peux pas
l'attraper par ses habits j'arrive
j'attrape à la main comme ça donc je
suis comme ça dans le vide je tiens à la
main et là on est au 19e étage donc ça
fait quand même bizarre et euh et là le
le la personne vraiment détresse qui
voulait vraiment finir avec la vie elle
me tape et M là je crois aime lâche et
du coup il chute il chute et vous avez
été mal combien de de temps après cet
événement d'abord est-ce que vous êtes
toujours
à chaque fois je pars pour une personne
en jeter dans le vide c'est une
intervention qui me revient donc j'y
pense toujours
le risque et on pense aux dangers au
risque
tu es parce que c'est un métier
dangereux quoi le risque zéro n'est pas
essaie de faire au maximum mais il y a
toujours un risque
[Musique]
dans nos yeux
l'histoire de Vincent les champs
militaires me rappellent que le grimpe
comme tous les pompiers de Paris côtoie
la mort et la souffrance au quotidien
de 2005 à 2012 sur l'ensemble de la
France 98 pompiers sont décédés en
service
vous avez froid c'est dommage
on est en présentation l'objectif
[Applaudissements]
je deviens un vrai professionnel
pour ma troisième journée de formation
je ne vais pas quitter la terre ferme je
vais m'y engouffrer
alors là on se trouve au spéléodrome de
Rosny-sous-Bois alors on est amené à
rencontrer Jean de situation bah avec
les catacombes donc c'est pas vraiment
de la spéléologie mais en fait c'est
surtout le milieu qui qui nous rappelle
un petit peu cette ambiance en vague
d'être dans le noir sous terre
je suis une accumulation au milieu il
finit moi
par deux fois l'année dernière les
équipes du grimpe sont allés chercher
des personnes bloquées sous terre
coincés dans les catacombes les
carrières souterraines creusées sur
Paris
ils m'ont visité en une grue et
maintenant ils veulent que je m'enfonce
dans un puits sans fond
oh c'est haut
épargner tellement
tu vas pouvoir faire balançoire avec mes
petites suspendre jeter
OK
ça part à part
tu regardes en bas non
je maintiens ça n'a rien de naturel et
encore moins dans le noir
pour ta sécurité il y a pas de problème
j'ai l'impression de descendre au fond
d'une mine les paroisses
l'atmosphère est humide
tiens un vrai professionnel
au fond je rejoins Julien casque blanc
pompier de Paris depuis 14 ans membre du
gramme de 7 le fait qu'on vous appelle
généralement quand la situation est
bloquée c'est quand même 90% des des cas
c'est-à-dire que quand le pompier
classique peut pas peut pas aller plus
loin on vous appelle en fait il faut il
faut voir le grain comme une comme un
outil les pompiers qui sont les premiers
à intervenir on leur apporte des
conseils techniques et puis ça nous
permet aussi d'évacuer les gens ou les
sortir d'une situation dont ils ont pas
l'habitude en fin de compte mais pour
nous c'est plus commun puisque on
s'entraîne pour ça et qu'est-ce qui vous
a attiré dans cette unité en particulier
c'est le travail en hauteur donc le
travail sur corde le travail de manœuvre
de force parce que c'est très
intéressant c'est très technique de
déplacer quelqu'un d'un point A vers un
point B avec des obstacles au milieu
c'est c'est un casse-tête chinois et
c'est vrai que c'est un côté hyper
attrayant parce que c'est c'est très
spécifique c'est un peu pour ceux qui
nous regardent ce qu'on faisait à
l'école contre la mécanique avec des
jeux de poulet savoir comment est-ce
qu'on était très mauvaise maintenant
très très très bon
pas vite supermanas
[Musique]
en moyenne 150 fois par an les
évacuations ne sont pas virtuelles les
victimes sont bien réelles
[Musique]
un chantier à deux pas du périph
un ouvrier est tombé sous des grilles il
est coincé au fond de la fosse
les sapeurs traditionnels conçu très
vite qu'il ne pourrait pas le sortir
seul ils ont appelé le grain
ça va monsieur vous enlève le masque
ce n'est plus un exercice l'ambiance a
changé les gars ne risquent les
attitudes les regards ne sont pas les
mêmes la concentration et la rigueur
sont palpables
il faut faire attention si la colonne
vertébrale est touchée le risque de
paralysie est à prendre très au sérieux
qui est tombé qui a traumatisme au
niveau de sa colonne vertébrale donc on
doit le remonter avec le plus de
précautions possibles
[Applaudissements]
par le dessous
[Musique]
en bleu les pompiers de la caserne la
plus proche
arrivé les premiers sur place ils ont
médicalisé la victime
en rouge les gars du grain ils vont
évacuer le brancard
faudra tirer tranquillement pour pas que
ça frotte de trop et puis vous le PS on
va vous laisser ici sur cette zone là on
va se mettre sur les barrières
Julien a pris la main on entend plus que
lui
à Joe là-haut allez silencieux pour
faire la mise en tension du dispositif
on va voir en même temps si la barquette
elle est bien équilibrée allez fraction
sur le treuil mise en tension
ça va Sylvain
vous pouvez mettre sur le mur et les
gars sur le muret vous pouvez vous
mettre là Monsieur
la difficulté ne vient ni de la hauteur
ni de la profondeur mais de l'étroitesse
de la fosse doucement attention
je vais l'enlever
en 30 minutes chrono le grimpe a extrait
l'ouvrier accidenté
si une opération qui s'est bien déroulée
dans l'ensemble on a eu une sortie
chaotique parce que le lieu était quand
même assez exigu et confiné c'est pas
très haut il y avait que 5 m mais ça
suffit pour nous embêter un petit peu
mais on s'en est bien sorti et le
monsieur il a eu mal quand il a fallu le
mettre dans le brancard mais la sortie
en elle-même c'est bien passé il a pas
eu mal donc voilà là il a été pris en
charge par nos collègues et il se dirige
tranquillement sur l'hôpital le grimpe
n'est pas médicalisé les pompiers
conventionnels ont repris la main
[Musique]
fin d'après-midi retour au cœur de Paris
le grimpe est à nouveau en manœuvre
[Musique]
24h sur 24 365 jours par an une équipe
de grimpe et de garde invariablement en
attendant l'intervention les hommes
s'entraînent et de préférence le plus
haut possible
[Musique]
sur le toit de la tour Montparnasse à
200 mètres du sol les rues de Paris
semblent bien petites
[Musique]
sur les grandes tours il ne s'agit pas
d'évacuer une victime par la fenêtre
mais il faut pouvoir secourir les
laveurs de vitres coincés dans leur
nacelle
[Musique]
les hommes du grain pâte d'ordre la
tombe Montparnasse c'est le plus belle à
pic de la capitale
[Musique]
200 mètres de vide absolu un bonheur
quand même les plus beaux monuments de
Paris Tour Eiffel les Invalides le loup
on est sur un beau terrain
d'entraînement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vu imprenable sur Paris je comprends
qu'ils aiment leur métier et qu'on se
bouscule au portillon pour intégrer ce
groupe
[Musique]
c'est mon quatrième jour à Saint-Denis
je ne sais pas ce que mes camarades
d'immersion m'ont réservé j'appréhende
une forêt en région parisienne un petit
matin glacé d'hiver et un viaduc
désaffecté
ambiance commando
comment
si on tient un café une heure
ils ont une heure de jogging dans les
pattes et ce n'est que le début
ouais c'est une petite journée spéciale
une petite petite journée à thème en
milieu naturel sur un site équipé école
on les boost un petit peu pour voir un
peu leur activité donc ceux qui
réussiront passeront le deuxième niveau
donc l'IMP 2 l'IMP 2 c'est la formation
pour devenir sauveteur au sein du grimpe
issu de toutes les cases de Paris 10
pompiers confirmés jouent aujourd'hui la
suite de leur carrière face à Juan leur
futur patron
ok donc là on est parti pour la journée
d'accord à faire de l'équipement donc ce
que vous a dit le chef donc à évolution
à monter descente et puis après on a une
petite remontée sur qui reviennent je
veux voir personne inactif donc sécurité
à bloc des questions des blessés des
malades pour ceux qui le sentent pas qui
ont le vertige et qui ont peur vous le
dites de suite on perd pas de temps ça
sera simple
vous avez froid c'est dommage
parce que là vous allez avoir hyper
chaud
pendant 4 heures ils vont enchaîner
monter sur paroi
progression dans le vide
attention au tyrolienne
et descendons rappelle
les instructures du grimpe observent
juge et corrigent sans ménagement on est
bien chez des militaires oh là là
d'accord elle passe comment là d'accord
déjà si ton mousqueton assis là s'il
bloque la poignée l'accès à ta poignée
ça va te verrouiller ton descendeur à
valeur donc
il faut pas 3h pour installer une
corde sur un descendeur
eh non mais ouais tu as des marches tu
marches
tu t'accordes est-ce que tu as regardé
où est-ce qu'elle est passé ta corde en
haut là
tu remontes par la corde bien sûr
et tu viens pas crever les yeux de ta
poignée avec ta langue je cours et tu
resserre tout ça
tu es pas à fond
la différence elle va se faire sur quoi
entre entre tous je pense sur
ceux qui vont assimiler rapidement tout
ce qu'on leur a donné combien tout
ingérer et qui vont pouvoir reproduire
ceux qui vont arriver à reproduire
exactement ce qu'on leur a demandé
et on leur demande aussi de la
motivation qui montre qu'ils aient envie
aussi de d'intégrer le groupe
tu veux un verre chaud
parce que le gars qui apprend en montant
là
tu as eu froid toi
c'est tout ce que j'ai voulu faire
depuis
ça fait 8 ans que je suis à brigade et
on entend parler de tous les jours quoi
c'est c'est
ils étaient 20 candidats ce soir ils ne
sont plus que 10
après une dernière session d'épreuve de
15 jours seul 7 seront apte à rejoindre
le grimpe mais uniquement quand l'un des
18 postes se libérera
pour finir en beauté ils m'ont prévu une
virée dans les airs
dans quelques cas extrêmes le grain n'a
pas le choix l'arme ultime c'est
l'hélico une manœuvre très technique qui
demande une parfaite maîtrise et une
parfaite coordination
si vous la prenez comme ça cette poignée
et qui a un mouvement de machine mais là
vous allez vous péter le poignet ou le
ou l'avant-bras donc là poignée toujours
la main comme ça ce qui est
[Musique]
engager en général pour faire le check
ça marche allez on est parti
l'hélico de la protection civile
redécole il va nous récupérer depuis les
airs
pour nous déposer quelque part au milieu
de la scène
les gars du grain doivent chacun faire
trois vols d'entraînement par an sans
cela ils ne sont pas autorisés à
intervenir sur un carré réel
je contrôle puissant on est toujours bon
en avant décollage ok je décolle
le treuil est équipé d'un câble de 90
mètres il peut soulever jusqu'à 270 kg
l'hélico peut transporter deux civières
et 4 sauveteurs une machine très
efficace
en compter on est 17 ou pas instable
toujours stable ok
je vais sécuriser tout le monde
le sauveur du grain doit se laisser
faire et suivre les instructions le
pilote et le mécanicien du treuil sont
les seuls maîtres de la manœuvre
on est en présentation l'objectif est à
200 mètres
finalement c'est quand même dingue ils
sont 18 à raison de trois vols chacun ça
fait plus de 50 volts d'entraînement par
an tout ça pour deux interventions
étriers chaque année mais c'est le prix
l'efficacité
c'est la phase finale la plus délicate
ok j'ai l'objectif toujours
allez c'est parti en
décembre tout à l'heure des stocks en
décembre
en avance pour 30 possible 25 ans
j'arrête de descendre je suis en 11 on
décembre 10 en avant à droite pour deux
les derniers mètres sont les plus
compliqués le pilote ne voit rien tout
se passe sous l'hélico c'est le mécano
qui dirige la manœuvre maître
un petit peu chaud à poser
trois à droite
de haut à droite
à droite face à droite machin position à
l'aveugle le pilote doit poser deux
hommes sur une plateforme qui vue du
ciel doit ressembler à une boîte
d'allumettes
la manœuvre est terminée retour sur la
terre ferme
[Musique]
on sent la puissance de la machine quand
on est suspendu et quand on je crois que
le plus gilet c'est quand on avance en
même temps enfin quand on est suspendu
c'est absolument génial
[Musique]
ultime retour à la caserne fin de
l'expérience que j'ai adoré mais avant
de pied bagages souvenez-vous à mon
arrivée j'ai loupé mon examen d'entrée
aujourd'hui c'est ma dernière chance
à deux
allez allez
[Musique]
à vous maintenant
allez je peux pas partir sans tout
raconter à Carole
bah moi j'ai pour être tout à fait ma
grand-mère paternelle habitait en face
de la caserne des pompiers de la rue
Mesnil donc j'ai toujours vu depuis tout
petit les camions de pompiers et j'ai pu
faire du camion de pompier du painpon et
travailler en pompier même si en théorie
puis ça se mérite de porter la fameuse
bande rouge mais bon j'ai eu la chance
de la porter j'ai fait des tas de choses
que je ne ferais que je ne referai plus
jamais dans ma vie il est évident que
j'aurais pas sauté du haut du Pont-Neuf
même sur un pari idiot si j'avais pas
les pompiers à côté de moi j'aurais
jamais descendu un truc de 40 mètres en
rappel sans qu'il met pas qu'on
m'expliquer et s'il n'avait pas été à
côté de moi et évidemment et tout ce que
j'ai fait je n'aurais pas pu le faire
sans eux
regardez un moment de cette expérience
je pense que j'ai eu très très peur sur
la grue le premier jour et je me suis
dit ça va être très très difficile c'est
cette immersion parce que parce que j'ai
pas l'habitude parce que le vide même si
j'ai pas le vertige ça me fait peur et
ça fait peur à beaucoup de gens mais en
fait en trois jours je me suis affranchi
pas mal de choses notamment de cette
peur de vide mais ça c'est grâce au bon
pied bon courage pour ton prochain
immersion
c'est normal c'est normal c'est pour ça
tu sais bien je suis sportif
je t'envoie des bisous
c'est 96 heures d'immersion s'arrête là
pas du temps je vous je vous remets
cette belle combinaison j'ai eu honneur
à apporter pour lancer quelques jours
merci pour votre accueil merci beaucoup
je vous laisse merci à vous
laisser un souvenir le petit galon adieu
dort
et c'est sans moi qui reprennent la
route dévoué à la sécurité des Parisiens
[Musique]